to outperform trial and error
intellectually
you need at least a thousand IQ points
which which I'm sure you know you're
close but but even then you can get that
that High I mean there were a few people
I mean nobody nobody you know gets uh
close to a fraction of that anyway so do
you realize that that's the the my main
idea when I say that you'd rather be
anti-fragile than intelligent any time
and you look at the data and you realize
that all the big gains we have had in
any field almost any field except the
nuclear came from trial and error by
people who didn't have much of a clue
about the process
foreign
there's something technical I want to
mention here about there's a domain
that's purely anti-fragile benefits with
the entrepreneurship
okay and I was calling for National
entrepreneur day why because you know as
he's saying losing a little bit of money
all the time to make big gains
isn't part of human nature except in
California it is
but it's respectable to fail they say
fail early so you can fail seven times
for your big thing
so collectively you have thousands of
people failing for everyone succeeding
and the person succeeding also have has
failed probably seven or eight times
before okay so the deal with failure but
it has small upside how do they do it
once they made it respectable and I want
to make more respectable but there's a
mathematical property that's quite
shocking
that that came out from options I
realized and I call it the Philosopher's
Stone and I and no nobody's getting the
following the trial and error
isn't really trial and error
trial and error is trial with small
error
if you have small error and big upside
what is anti-fragile has small losses
big gains so trial and error has to have
small losses big gains so if you model
it you realize that to outperform trial
and error intellectually
you need at least a thousand IQ points
which which I'm sure you know you're
close but but even then you don't get
that that High I mean there were a few
people I mean nobody nobody you know
gets uh close to a fraction of that
anyway so do you realize that that's the
the my main idea when I say that you'd
rather be anti-fragile than intelligent
any time and you look at the data
and you realize that all the big gains
we have had
in any field almost any field except the
nuclear
and even in medicine except for ACT
drugs came from trial and error by
people who didn't have much of a clue
about the process
trying
you you try you discover
you're rational enough to know that what
you found is better than we had before
so this this is where and and in this
Fat Tony Story Fat Tony
uh you know I'm I'm just like talking to
a shrink I realize there's a fat Tony in
me that Tony was was a sad character I
didn't know I was Fat Tony but now I
realized that I am Fat Tony in fact only
half the date right from the half the
day now all right now things come out
you know in this conversation watch out
when you talk publicly with a
psychologist next time so the The Fat
Tony what whether I got this idea of Fat
Tony from nitri I don't know if you've
heard of crazy the notion of creative
destruction but cementry
knee tree has joined us
the dionysian in US and he has the
Apollonia the Apollonia likes order
knowledge Serenity Harmony
and of course predictability and and see
things and there's that dark force
that's hard to understand
the the dionysian right and Innes and
then there's he he found that that when
the balance got disrupted with Socrates
So Fat Tony goes to argue Socrates
so there's a tuple Fat Tony who doesn't
believe in knowledge he believes in
tricks and no theory he believes in
doing and you try to keep trying till
something works and you get rich and
then you go have lunch and this is why
it's called Fat Tony he has a lot of a
lot of meals
so he's he's arguing with Socrates
and then
he was able to express that sentence
that Nietzsche Nietzsche really
understood he said
the mistake people tend to make
is to think that whatever you don't
understand is stupid that was a fat Tony
they say the unintelligible is not
necessarily unintelligent
and anti-fragility is harvesting the
unintelligible is harvesting what we
don't understand and this is what we've
done take the Industrial Revolution take
California you know the the Silicon
Valley take in medicine the discoveries
is Harvest things that are intelligible
with small errors and big gains and
doing it in an industrial scale and the
problem with education that's the only
thing I don't like about Academia is one
had we put Bill Gates
through an entire you know college
experience we wouldn't have had
Microsoft right
okay so the problem is Industrial
Revolution happened with people who
weren't really academics and once we got
there then they wanted the state
you know to create you know invention
from top down not bottom up that's the
problem education inhibits risk-taking
that's my only point I'm going to
simulate a process here
this has not been a book by the way all
right this is outside the book
simulate the process where you have two
people competing one person has
knowledge
and his brother has
um
has a complexity
has a convex payoff
look at and the difference between them
would be the difference between
knowledge
and the convex payoff
will be what I call the convexity bias
I assimilated it and look how big it is
well visibly
this explains something
that people so far couldn't understand
you know trial and error okay has errors
in it do you agree
so in in history books history of
Technology people
usually oppose trial and error versus
theoretical knowledge
but they never were able to work with
trial and era they didn't understand it
was had to be convex
trial and error relies on luck but luck
can hurt you
so it was never modeled as an option
technology as an option if this model is
an option and I'm sure there's all the
questions so I'll leave I'll go over
this very quickly if I were to model it
as an option trial and error
then it would have it would be something
that loves volatility
you see option loss volatility and you
you can have policies that come from it
my idea of planner is very simple
when I'd much rather have series of
options like have a long Highway with a
lot of exits then be locked in into top
down plan like a highway with no exit a
destination you exit that's it so assume
you want to change your mind you're in
trouble okay
particularly if you don't know Russian
and you're in Russia right that's how
they build their thing so the the the so
you have two approaches to knowledge one
is top down
and one is bottom up so here there are
about 75 pages that should upset a lot
of academics
because you take I took some you know
evidence
which includes my own field which was to
be derivatives that a lot of things that
we think we believe come from top down
knowledge and theoretical knowledge
effectively come from tinkering
dressed up later
as having been developed by theoretician
which includes these Corners up here
Euclid people say you have to learn
euclidean geometry
and look at all these things that were
built after Euclid all right for about
15th 16th century people were building
things that never heard who Euclid was
all right the Romans were extremely
heuristic very very very
um experience based
and they did everything using this
convex knowledge how was convex
knowledge it's exactly like cooking
you have very little to lose by adding
an ingredient and tasting
all right if it works
now you have a better recipe
if it fails you lost nothing
so things in knowledge no no academic
would want to I mean I'm a professor in
an engineering department no academic
except Engineers because they're nice
people no academic would accept the
notion
that knowledge can come from a bottom-up
you know so we have evidence of what I
call lecturing Birds how to fly a lot of
science comes from technology
but look at a definition Google
technology science and we explain that
technology is application of science to
practical things exactly opposite
anyway so this is my my option Theory
thing I don't know if it upset many of
you but typically it upsets academic
yeah I mean if it feels like there's a
lot of people who want it you who have a
point on the map that they want to get
to and then they have to figure out how
to get to there but really everyone
should just move from where they are
today right I think that's what's so
important about the team is it's great
yeah exactly all three of us up here are
tinkerers like I you know was early on
tinkering with Twitter for philosophy
um you know you sahil you're tinkering
with gumroad in like the weird way that
you run it uh you're tinkering on the
crowdfunding side you were tinkering on
rolling funds I was tinkering on how to
mechanize Angel Investing in BC I was
kind of opening things up with the blogs
on Venture hacks and that was tinkering
Ben you were tinkering on strategory and
dithering like we're tinkerers right and
I think most successful creators are
ultimately tinkerers they're just sort
of playing around at the edges of their
field on something that is interesting
to them it's not really with some strong
motive it's play it's not really with a
motive to like create something great
out of it because they're they're
genuinely interested and most tinkering
is wasted it's like when your kids are
playing most that time is you know quote
unquote wasted but once in a while it
will result in something which for a
child might be a hobby and for an adult
it might be a vocation yeah I think it's
also inherently low status right I think
you you kind of spend years not making
any money and maybe not building an
audience and getting really good at a
skill but you don't have any any way to
know if you know if that's actually
going to turn into anything uh that's
sort of turning into something is you
know kind of happens all at once 10
years later
well I think there's something too about
learning how to be in your particular
moment and people get so fixed well five
ten years in the future particularly
when it comes to the career and the real
danger is you end up like succeeding and
then you ended up in a place that's just
not very relevant or interesting or
there's a ton of competition and I look
back like how I ended up what I'm doing
and
yeah it has a quote you know you look
backwards and you connect the docs
warning I was you know maximizing
whatever I was doing at that particular
time that's what pays off and you see so
many people get so distracted about
where they want to go and they don't
take full advantage of the spot that
they're in and then you look back I was
like man I wish I would have spent that
time better because I could have really
used that experience and it's already
too late
you certainly don't want to plan for
trying to predict too much in the future
like I think the worst title you can
possibly have in your bios futurist
first of all it's just tone deaf but
when someone says futurist and it's like
ah you know they're trying too hard
they're trying too hard to live in the
future when yes you're right your only
moment of power and knowledge is a
present you just act from the present
it's not to say you shouldn't have like
goals and plans and those kinds of
things it's kind of nice to have them
loosely held but if you stick too
closely to them you'll miss reality
reality is very fluid and very complex
and it's much more about navigating from
the small set of options presented to
you much more Choose Your Own Adventure
style than you know top and down Soviet
style planning with five-year plans and
I'm gonna get to Aid and B and C you
know I think the other thing with that
too you do need a long-term goal but
that gives you a way to think about the
immediate term options right like so I
have three options today that are not my
long-term goal I know the general
direction I'm going so I can choose this
one that maybe is sub-optimal or maybe
seems further but I'm building up a
particular skill or getting a particular
sort of experience that will get me
closer to that long-term goal without
having yeah like a five-year plan I
think that's the exact like the exact
wrong way to go about it
well I think it's it's what's so
difficult when you when someone asks
someone who's successful like why did
you become successful and it basically
forces I feel like the person to lie
because you you look back connect the
dots and then you can't help but sort of
believe that it was it sort of happened
on purpose and that you sort of had you
know you can't remember what it was like
to not know where you were going
yeah first I picked sperm number three
billion 768 412 that then routed its way
to egg number 14 on the exact date of
blah blah blah so what it's funny oh
sorry
oh no I I was funny I told the story on
this week's exponent exactly where it's
hilarious that I'm known as the
newsletter guy
because I
best it was a total accident where I had
I had the vision to have a subscription
base fund was all website Centric and it
was a total disaster and I I actually
watched it on Thursday
it was a total mess I tore it out over
the weekend I told people like look I
just screwed up the website hostile for
anyone that's not a subscriber I it's
the wrong direction I'm just gonna email
you if you subscribe I'll email you
additional stuff in addition to the
website
it's like literally like a spur of the
moment I have to fix this problem figure
it out how am I going to get content to
my subscribers without having a bad
experience for not enough subscribers
and then now today I'm the newsletter
guy it's like so there when you look
backwards if you're actually honest
about it there's a lot of luck for
certain a lot of like just in the right
way taking the right choice it's funny
Angelus has a similar story because uh
first there was a network for sharing
deal flow that nivi and I built or
mostly nivi built called the pound deal
flow Network there's literally a little
social network with a feed and you can
follow people and nobody used it and
then he built a Google group and nobody
used that either and then finally we're
like screw it we're this notice we're
just freaking email them the data and
that was Angel list
[Music]
what fools call wasting time is most
often the best investment Nasim taleb
from the bed of bros crustace you can't
connect the dots looking forward you can
only connect them looking backwards
Steve Jobs ideas don't come out fully
formed they only become clear as you
work on them you just have to get
started Mark Zuckerberg now I want to
share some of my thoughts in my
perspective the theoretical knowledge is
important to have a minimum of good
judgment to know more or less what path
to take and also detect the BS and
nonsense that exists in most Industries
especially important in new emerging and
still to fully regulate Industries
because this will have lots of scams
around as you acquire these foundational
actions what Elon Musk would call First
principle thinking you will be ready to
follow the path or paths that you want
in that path you execute through trial
and error and learn from the errors and
Implement that new knowledge into your
previous knowledge base so I think the
theoretical knowledge is useful for
having a first principle stinking base
and a minimum understanding necessary
for a given activity but then all real
and Innovative learning will come from
the bottom up Knowledge from the
outcomes of an iterations you learn and
rationally decide to move one way or the
other just like Warren Buffett and
Charlie Monger spend most of their days
thinking and reading and inevitably
learning from theoretical knowledge
older investment decisions to action
that is the execution part are
absolutely opportunistic and they keep
learning from each mistaken decision the
key I think is to never stop learning
from either theoretical knowledge or
tinkering because just like compounding
in Investments knowledge does also
compounds and we are never too wise at
anything in absolute terms as Charlie
Monger says develop into a lifelong
self-learner through voracious reading
cultivate curiosity and strive to become
a little wiser every day would you like
to get access to the finest nuggets from
the best non-fiction books out there if
you do you should check out short form
for disclosure short form is not
sponsoring this video but there is an
affiliate Link in the video description
why am I promoting short form well my
purpose through this channel is to
collect valuable insights from videos of
people that I deeply admire now imagine
if you can easily get the most valuable
insights from the best non-fiction books
this is what you can find on short form
a curated selection of the best books
and for each book you can find a
carefully crafted summary in which all
the book's relevant ideas are analyzed
this is why I absolutely love to read on
short form and would recommend it to
anyone as Charlie Munger argues to have
a good unsuccessful life you have to
create a mental model from all the big
ideas from all the big disciplines and
short film can be extremely helpful for
this matter as it literally extracts all
the big ideas from the best non-fiction
books helping you to create this mental
model in a faster and more efficient way
and with these valuable ideas becoming
second nature to us over time I think we
will be able to build our best lives by
standing on the shoulders of giants asir
Isaac Newton would put it now the way I
personally read on short form is to pick
from my personal Library any book that
sparks my interest at that moment and
start reading it typically I will read
sometimes in the morning after waking up
sometimes at night before going to sleep
and many times I will do a short read on
the mobile phone app when for instance
I'm in a restaurant along waiting for
the food or commuting somewhere I
created my personal Library by quickly
scan through all the books on short form
and for any book to make it on my
library it has not only to interest me
but it also must fulfill at least one of
two conditions one is that I already
know the author of the book from an
interview in some podcast or any other
source that I personally trust and the
other is that the book itself has been
publicly recommended by people who I
deeply admire if you are interested in
short form you can visit my special link
shortfarm.com picking nuggets I will
also leave the link in the description
of the video by joining with my
affiliate link you will be supporting
this Channel and you can have unlimited
access for 5 days and a 20 discount on
the annual subscription if you do choose
to keep going after the end of your
trial thanks for watching if you enjoyed
the greeting content in this video you
will love our newsletter where you can
get in your email all the greeting
content plus the latest things that I've
been pondering to subscribe all always
for free find the link below in the
description